what i hope to do in this video is
several examples from the khan academy
exercise on negative number addition and
subtraction equivalent expressions and
this is just to really make sure that we
we fully digested how we can compute
with negative and positive numbers and
also the properties that we the the
properties of arithmetic that we can
apply when we compute with them so let's
get started so it says raul tried to
evaluate an expression step by step
all right so they start with the
expression they give us the steps and
then they say find raul's mistake and we
have step one step two step three or
maybe raul did not make a mistake
and like always i encourage you to pause
the video and try to solve it on your
own before i work through it
all right so let's look at this first
step it says 3 minus negative 5 minus 7.
and it looks like he correctly
recognized that subtracting a negative 5
is the same thing as adding a positive
5. so he replaced the minus negative 5
with the plus 5 right over there
so that seems right
all right
so step one seems all right
then what does he do next so he has two
options he could say 3 plus 5 is equal
to eight and then subtract seven from
that and he would get one
or he could even say five minus seven is
negative two and then add that to three
and get one
and it looks like raul tried to go that
second way
but he made a slight mistake because he
said five minus seven is equal to two
not negative two five minus seven should
be negative two but he wrote a positive
two right over here so his mistake is in
step two and then obviously step three
becomes wrong because of step two but
this is this is where he first this is
where he first makes the mistake
let's do several more of these
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to 6 plus negative 4
minus 5.
all right so let's look at all the
options here
so this first one let's see it has a
negative 5
well the negative 5 this minus five if
you put it out front you could you could
represent it as a negative five
then it has a negative four here
and here we're adding a negative four so
or i guess you could say we're we have
negative five we have minus four here
which is the same thing as adding a
negative 4. so that seems reasonable and
then you have plus 6
and you just had a positive 6 right over
here so this one actually seems
equivalent it's just the order they just
switch the order instead of instead of
adding the six first they had this
positive six last instead of having the
minus five at the end they put a
negative five in the beginning and
instead of saying adding negative four
they just said minus four but these are
all equivalent so this one is going to
be an equivalent expression now let's
see this one has
so it has the six and the minus four
they just change the order but now it
has positive five and that's not going
to work because we have a we're
subtracting five out here so if we want
to put the five out front it needs to be
a negative 5. so this isn't going to be
right i'm not going to select none of
the above because i found a choice that
is equivalent
let's keep going it's a lot of fun
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to negative 4 plus 4 plus 5
in parentheses so if i were to compute
this i would say negative 4 plus and i
would add the 4 and the 5 first and i
would get 9 so it would be negative 4
plus 9 which is equal to 5.
so let's see
0 plus 5 well that's going to be equal
to 5 so that's equivalent
i mean i can just do it again negative 4
plus
negative 4 plus 9 is 5. it's the same
thing as 9 minus 4. and this right here
is 5.
now this is negative 4 minus 4 which
would be negative 8
and then plus 5 would be negative 3.
so that's not equivalent in order to be
equivalent this should evaluate out to
be 5. so i'm not going to select that
i'm not going to select none of the
above because i already found a choice
that i like
let's do a few more of these so once
again which are equivalent
negative five plus seven minus negative
three
so here you have negative five plus
seven
plus three well that makes sense if you
subtract a negative 3 that's the same
thing as adding a 3 and they didn't
change the negative 5 plus 7 they didn't
change the negative 5 plus 7 so i'll
definitely select this one definitely
select that
now let's look at this one
so negative five here they're
subtracting a five so that seems
reasonable
adding seven they're adding seven
here they're subtracting a negative
three which is the same thing as adding
a positive three
here they just have a they're just they
just have a negative 3 here if this was
a positive 3 then we'd be in business
but this is a negative 3 so this isn't
going to work so i will not select that
and i won't select none of the above
because i found a choice
let's do let's do one more of these
which of the following expressions are
equivalent to
x plus y and since the parenthesis
around it i would do that first and then
i would subtract z select all that apply
all right so here
here they they have z plus x plus y
so they have the x plus y part
but then they have a positive z there or
they have a z here while over here they
have minus z so if they wrote a negative
z here this and this would have been
equivalent they don't have a negative z
here so i would not i would not select
that one
now this one you have x plus y minus z
well this they just change the
parentheses instead of doing the x plus
y first they're doing the y minus z
first
and this is you know this this goes back
to addition and subtraction you have the
associative property you could associate
these you could start with these adding
these two first and then you do the
subtraction or you could do the
subtraction first and then you add this
one and if you don't believe me you
could try it out with some numbers and
encourage you to try it out with some
negative numbers but it will indeed all
work out all they did is they changed
where the parentheses are they did the y
minus z first and then they add they do
the y minus z and then they add it to
the x as opposed to doing the x plus y
first and then subtracting the z so i
would go
i would go with that one